I am Kristen Bell and I am an arsonist  Kristen Bell makes history as the SAG  Awards first-ever host that's the first  time first person first lady I think my  first initiative as first lady will be  cyberbullying because I have yet to see  any progress made on that problem quite  yet and I'm looking at you Tony Hale  Kristen through in a Melania Trump jab  during her open monologue but she also  dedicated the show to struggling actors  who are watching this in a studio  apartment in Koreatown with their five  roommates downing their nightly dinner  of canned tuna and the wave of women and  men in Hollywood lending their voices to  the times up movement let's make sure  that we're leading the charge with  empathy and with diligence because fear  and anger never win the race and I also  marked the first time the SAG Awards  were handed out by all female presenters  there's a lot of ladies involved we're  letting the women sort of take center  stage  [Music]